Francia amaneció este viernes
trasnochada y el ambiente es tenso en
varias ciudades en este momento la
dirección central de seguridad pública
mantiene una vigilancia reforzada de
edificios y lugares públicos sensibles
esto según una nota consultada por la
cadena Estatal Por ese motivo El
Ejecutivo pidió a sus ministros Cancelar
todos sus desplazamientos en el terreno
hasta nuevo aviso y reforzar Igualmente
la seguridad de los diputados y
senadores por temor a represalias contra
ellos en el terreno Qué sucede en este
momento pues hay cerca de cinco mil
personas en las calles de henna la
capital de Bretaña la situación allí es
tan delicada que el ministro del
interior ordenó el despliegue de la crs8
esa unidad de policial especializada en
violencia urbana no es para menos anoche
hubo choques violentos con la policía
saqueos el ayuntamiento vandalizado y 26
incendios que requirieron intervención
de los bomberos aquí en París se
reportan pequeños grupos de
manifestantes cerca de la estación de
Ferro de Lyon en las ciudades de burdeos
y Tulum varias decenas de indignados
bloquearon el tránsito ferroviario otro
bloqueo en curso en las inmediaciones de
la fábrica de piezas de automóviles de
oddham cerca de la frontera con Bélgica
acciones previstas también en dunker que
cerca de Caleb Puerto clave para el
transporte entre Francia y el Reino
Unido y protestas reportadas también en
exams y Rubén esas también pacíficas un
punto a subrayar se trata de
manifestaciones aisladas improvisadas y
repentinas